good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Thursday
everyone it's me our girl Jax wow Jax
how long have you been out of the game
the morning toast did I say that I don't
think I said that I don't think I did
already the gas lighting begins you guys
Jackie you're really you're not gonna be
happy when you hear this playback you
said you know what I do I do believe you
I'm not gonna die on this hill I
probably said that
you said it I probably did and I'm sorry
but I like it
I'm sorry but
um I like it nothing like a self quote
to start an episode of the toasty turdy
luya hi Derm
I'm doing good it's so good to be back
with Jax like oh my God you know I do
know but you've had such a fun-filled
guest-filled week yeah and I know how
you love chit chatting with everyone
chit chat I love chit chatting with the
girls and I know how you love like
making the most and thirsting in my
absence
gulp gulp gulp gulp gulp but I am back
for a little Audio Only episode because
Claudia is going to Stagecoach today
yeah while you are listening to this
episode I will be enroute to the West
Coast so we're doing a little Wednesday
night pre-record which is so crazy and
inauthentic of us no we used to do this
all the time because we used to just be
like on the go you were on tour like we
just would do night episodes and it's
been a while
it hits different
it hits different at night yeah it does
hit different we're always a little
kookier crazier at night but you if you
are a patreon member you know this side
of us because our patreon episodes are a
little toast after dark and that's where
we leave it all so um also speaking of
patreon like I'm sure a lot of listeners
are like Jax you're back we missed you
but Claudia and I just recorded a
patreon podcast episode that was really
so wonderful we caught up with each
other like a small content recap because
we were like
dreading doing the thing we set out to
do which was go through each other's
phones so Claudia and I took each
other's phones and went through each
other's Instagram search history
DMS venmo requests it's all on patreon
it was such a good episode I feel I saw
turdy like I never saw her before
yeah and it was nice for everyone to get
to hear from Jax
um so if you're by the way can I just
say that you feel the love everyone has
been like desperate for you I do feel
the love and I feel really loved and I
appreciate everyone and I love you right
back and I see all of your notes and
messages and it really means a lot
I have missed you and it's just like
there's nothing like I was right before
we started podcasting I was on the phone
with Shannon Ford and she was like um
because we're all gonna be together next
weekend too she was like will you record
an episode of my podcast with me and I
was like I will but like I just want to
let you know like I can like I have
nothing to say I've been just like
podcast podcast patreon patreon patreon
guest Coast like it really takes so much
more out of me to do an episode of the
toast without you and I was explaining
this to Shannon like we are really truly
like partners and we really split the
work 50 50 and this life of being a solo
business owner like I'm not down I
always you know I daydream sometimes oh
how nice would it be if I got to keep
all this if you didn't have you know
what split it right down in the middle
you can have it you can have the money
okay you can have all of it
okay I'm earning my keep
a hundred percent also just like the
emotional elements of like being the
host but also the interviewer and the
editor like doing everything and I love
the guest quotes because I feel like we
really cool like different conversations
um and I'm not saying anything bad I'm
just all I'm saying is I'm really happy
to have you here I'm really happy to be
here and to support you you're doing a
great job though like in the comments as
much as they love and long for me like
they're also just like turdy hits it out
at the park once again we love turdy and
Ben we love Tony and Taylor like can
Taylor be every day you know stuff like
that does that stuff hurt you when
you're like oh my God wish Ben would do
every single day yeah it's just like I
don't know if you guys know that that's
insulting because I don't know if you've
like put together that that would then
mean no put you out of a job no more me
but I don't think people mean it like
that I think they're just genuinely
trying to compliment the episode and
they inadvertently insult me but I know
it's really it's about intention versus
impact and I know that the intention was
not to insult me no no the intention was
to like leave a complimentary positive
comment about the episode but
inadvertently they're firing yeah
they're coming for my job yeah
um I will say like shout out to Taylor
strucker I feel like she's spin on the
toast like a lot of times and it can
when you go on any podcast a lot of
times it can become like repetitive and
she just has been so fresh she's really
been killing it I feel like I've seen
more comments than ever when people are
like bring back Taylor again like
Taylor's just killing it and I'm like
I'm grateful that she came and she's
just crushing it yeah and she I remember
when I podcasted with her a few times
when you were like on tour and stuff
like she makes the job a lot easier
because it feels like less like the an
interview and more just like couple of
posts hosting she's a true professional
host like you forget she was at Serious
XM radio for 11 years yeah but like Ben
comes on and he's like let's talk about
Ben
chaos reaction is we have some stories
today one of them is it's very been like
oh that's the other thing I've been
choosing the stories too I'll never
complain I'll never complain again
Jackie I'll never complain
so hard so good for our relationship I
saw in your episode with Sophia your
fifth and final was about Wendy's
selling canned chili but by the way
Jackie so interesting I'm interested I'm
so interested about that I needed to
know that's a story I chose for you
because you and I would have loved that
and Sophia she was playing the game she
was like oh cool she wouldn't make me
feel weird or anything but that was
totally a used story I know I wish I
could have been there to share my
thoughts but here's the thing if I
didn't see that episode of the toast I
would have never known that and that's
why we do what we do and why we service
these odd stories because Isn't that
cool we're sharing about the chili it is
cool and like that's really one of their
better products so I'm glad that they
recognize that too
they see each other
yeah they're self-aware just like you
me yeah that's like your claim to fame
is how self-aware you are I like to
think I'm self-aware are you co-signing
and saying I am yeah no I think you're
very afraid of being not self-aware
it is my biggest fear yeah yeah but so
you are very self-aware but like you
could be aware of other stuff too like
excuse me like you you could take some
time off of your self-awareness like
you're doing okay okay and then what
should I put that time towards what are
you trying to say oh I don't know you
could raise awareness for other things
like what I don't know I'm just saying
like you're doing a good job like don't
don't worry so much about it you know
what I mean okay you know I like 98 of
my mental
energy is used towards like what are
other people thinking about me like how
am I coming off am I okay it's really
pathetic no and that's another situation
where like I didn't mean that to sound
insulting no I know I know I was just
saying like you can like give yourself a
little Grace yeah wait totally I was as
I was falling asleep I almost last night
as I was falling asleep got up and
texted you because you have to watch
Young Sheldon you guys oh my God I saw
your story and I was gonna respond but I
tapped too quickly I did you get hacked
no everyone was like turdy be [__]
for real what are you talking about
because I posted on my story that young
Sheldon is the greatest television show
to ever be created and let me tell you
Jackie you would [__] love it it's
all about the campers by the way and I I
said this on the podcast with Sophia so
I don't want to be repetitive but like I
don't have any sort of uh Affliction to
The Big Bang Theory this is a a show
that's like associated with The Big Bang
Theory right it's a spin-off
I hate hate The Big Bang Theory I think
it's dumb and like I judge people who
think it's like a great show honestly
um even though you've never seen an
episode don't know what it's about right
I I have seen an episode and I generally
know what it's about oh okay Ben likes
it Ben likes it red flag continue agreed
moving on divorce
um so I weirdly started getting served
on Tick Tock like clips from the show
I'm like oh the show looks so cute
Jackie you would love it especially like
I know you're just like chilling at home
a lot this last week and like next week
you would love it it's a quick 20-minute
sitcom episodes It's camper energy up
the ass
honestly say
you will love it it's so sweet it's got
such heart it like teaches good lessons
like Jackie I I was not kidding me and
Ben are obsessed it's so good I was
being dead [__] serious where do you
watch it
HBO Max okay I have HBO Max
check it out like it's so good and
they're supposed to be known as
Maximilian literally the worst name I
hope they don't do that Rebrand ever I
know but
that's so weird still okay but will you
watch it uh yeah yeah I'm looking for a
show
she's looking for a show okay that works
for me that works for me that's such a
surprise I know like how not young
Sheldon am I no you're like old Belden
I'm so old Belden
it's so true I really am yeah
um so you're gonna join the Fast Five
today which is a delay have there been
any stories in like the two weeks that
you've been gone that you were like
dying to recap or anything that you was
painting you to like see me doing
without you so I feel like no like the
last two weeks like I did three episodes
last week and like I felt like you know
when we caught up with everything yeah
this week and then we also did like that
Monday episode two weeks ago where it
was like a huge recap of everything
we've ever thought in our lives
um this week the only standout stories
for me were Sophia Richie's wedding
which like I feel like is Thoroughly
recapped and it was just enjoyable to
consume
and Sydney Sweeney and Glenn Powell
liaising well do you have an update in
in your stories for that today I don't
because I imagine you've like been
talking about it every day
uh I only spoke about it once but there
was like a big update that came out
after the toast today one being Gigi
Paris who is Glenn Powell's
ex-girlfriend confirmed it she literally
made an Instagram story and was like
know your worth and don't forget to move
on or something like that and then I
think a rep for Sydney Sweeney told TMZ
like she's still very much engaged to
that nobody so this is all just drama
for their movie coming out
huh yeah I think there's smoke here me
too and really like I hate to be like
that type of person but I have been
watching a lot of their red carpet
photos and footage and like they do look
at each other very lovingly like it's
that you can see something in their eyes
okay but like to me that is acting like
it's a red it's a press junket for the
movie like that's promoting the movie
but I thought they recently filmed this
movie like that it wasn't coming out
imminently
it does feel like a quick turnaround
time
like frolicking in Australia just a few
weeks ago no you're right so that's a
little confusing but no if they're doing
like public appearances and looking
lovey-dovey that's giving Bradley Cooper
Lady Gaga yeah we gotta not get gaga it
was we all got caught up in that we all
I think we all got caught up in that
yeah but I also don't know how Glenn
Powell and Sydney Sweeney like get
together and don't fall in love with one
another yep I don't completely agree I
don't know how they just like shake
hands and say like great job on set
today and move on they're perfect for
each other they're perfect for each
other and I'm like it's it's bad that
there were other people involved if you
know if it is collateral
but like you can't fight fate I know
that's what we me and my Taylor's
tracker was on she was like it's so sad
because like cheating is wrong but like
who [__] cares like they're perfect
for each other sorry and there's not a
marriage in this equation right true no
there's an engagement yeah okay so it's
just like you know Young Love Tings yeah
you gotta Bop around if you're then if
you're career-wise because this is the
call I made with Taylor tell me if you
agree with this like Glenn Powell is
obviously a movie star he's been in so
many hits and he was just in Top Gun
like the biggest grossing movie of the
year yada yada but there's something
about him that's like not
Superstar famous like he should be yeah
agreed and he's missing like a
star-studded relationship
yeah
and this is it
agreed he hasn't just like clicked for
audiences yet in the way that he's
clicked for me
I know like I know you're a really big
fan of him and he's like a huge cult
following from that rom-com he did with
Zoe do I check people loved that movie
um but he's not and he's like he should
be because he was in Top Gun and he's in
these like big ass like franchises but
yeah I don't even think he's like that
recognizable now he's slowly starting as
the city Sweeney thing is helping and if
they really do date it would be great
for him yeah for me like his breakout
role is hidden figures
I see I didn't even know he was in that
John Glenn
oh yeah so cute John glennergy John
Glenn Powell
oh that was so much better than mine duh
and then you know what I wish would
happen like when people play historical
figures that like in other serieses they
would play them as well like
like for example in the crown when
Prince Philip meets the astronauts like
he met John Glenn and it should have
been Glenn Powell like and now I feel
like in other biopics like when people
are playing Elvis like in the background
of someone else's biopic like it should
be Austin Butler I know that's never
gonna [__] happen but like a little
continuity would really mean a lot to me
as a viewer can I tell you how much I
love that idea like that's a [__]
brilliant idea thank you so much I think
that it is too I know that there's like
it couldn't really never happen like
Studios contracts agents like you know
some
movies only get made with like agents
people you know whatever
um but then I wouldn't have to be like
is that you know is that June card who's
that supposed to be is that Johnny Cash
or Joaquin [__] Phoenix
yeah but the thing is like let's say
somebody made a movie today
Joaquin Phoenix is like 20 years out of
Walk the Line yeah it's no it's it's
tough the time period's really short I
would say there needs to be like a rule
if you make a movie within three years
of a movie being made with a fictional
representation
okay we'll give it five years then like
as a society we really encourage you to
use the actor who's known for the role I
love that idea thank you so much maybe
you'll bring some more of those good
ideas to the rest of the stories today
maybe I can't promise anything maybe
don't count on it
is that a tick tock sound no I just made
it up should somebody click it clip it
and make it a tick tock sound yes they
should I love that I love that for us
okay so let's get into said stories
without further Ado here are the Fast
Five said stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
a new sponsor Kendra Scott now one thing
about Kendra Scott is that she respects
mothers the whole company respects
mothers she is a leader in her field and
Kendra Scott the brand is a leading
Lifestyle brand founded on Three core
pillars Family Fashion and philanthropy
so as a mother herself Kendra believes
motherhood is full of big events and
even bigger Milestones but it's the
small everyday moments that matter the
most this Mother's Day let's celebrate
every moment and the women who've made
us who we are as a company made up of 96
women Kendra Scott officially recognizes
the Monday after Mother's Day as
Mother's Day Monday which is in an
annual company-wide holiday for all
their employees which I love oh we
should do that Claude noted Kendra
thanks to the tip
um and I feel like all the toasters know
and love Kendra Scott they've been
wearing Kendra Scott long before I have
but I recently got a ton of pieces from
um her new collection and it's really I
love like dainty gold jewelry like small
Huggies Hoops chain necklaces and they
had exactly what I was looking for and
it's also well made and it's so
beautiful and then you're supporting you
know this female founded and run company
and they're um with Mother's Day coming
up you know it's a good time to shop for
the most important woman in your life
yeah I'm just gonna send me such a cute
Mother's Day present a gold
um necklace that was customized and it
said roll dini and if you need a
Mother's Day gift for someone or for
yourself like I love like so many people
wear like a name necklace with their
baby love it yeah so now through
Mother's Day you can get 20 off fashion
and semi-fine jewelry when you use code
toast at kendrascott.com but also at a
Kendra Scott store so that's 20 off
fashion and semi-fine styles when you
use code toast either at checkout on
kendrascott.com or in a Kendra Scott
store remember to order by May 7th to
receive it in time for Mother's Day
standard exclusions apply today's
episode is also brought to you by
betterhelp so think you better help for
sponsoring today's episode
as you know therapy is a great tool for
getting to know yourself and doing that
can actually be a lifelong process
because we're always growing we're
always changing and it's always good to
just like be checking in with yourself
fine-tuning the gears in your brain
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding because
sometimes we don't know what we want or
why we react the way that we do until we
talk through things and better help
connects you with a licensed therapist
who can take you on that journey of
self-discovery from wherever you are so
one of the great things about better
help is a lot of like the awkward social
elements of traditional therapy are
completely removed because better help
is done entirely online so that means
when you want to talk to your therapist
you can do a video chat you can text you
can do just a standard phone call and
what's really great about it is if
you're not vibing with your therapist
like the one they matched you with which
is totally normal you don't have to have
like that awkward thing where you're
like in the waiting room and then you
don't come back and it's just so awkward
doing it all online it's super easy to
change your therapist and if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's done entirely online and
it's designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
you'll get matched with a licensed
therapist and of course you can switch
therapists at any time for no additional
charge discover your potential with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com toast to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help.com toast thank you
turdy Lou
you're welcome so our first story is
actually a story that's been um
unfolding over the week and now Morgan
wallen's label is denying the claim that
he was too drunk to perform his canceled
show so that is the rumor yes last
weekend Morgan Wallen was scheduled to
perform in Mississippi and right before
he was supposed to go on stage they
canceled the show citing that he lost
his voice
um then a tick tock user shared a video
of a security guard at the stadium
telling attendees after Sunday's show
that an allegedly intoxicated Morgan
couldn't walk and had to be taken out of
the venue by an ambulance he said losing
his voice is bull crap however both the
guards employer and Morgan's label have
shot down this claim they said quote a
hired employee of best crowd management
made false claims isn't related to last
night's Morgan Wallen concert and we do
not stand behind the detail in his
statement
by the way that Tick Tock that was going
around of those girls like talking to
the the security man at the arena and
filming him gave me such a pit because
like why would they put his face in it
you know right I mean yeah he's like
starting a rumor or whatever but like
this man's 100 fired and 100 losing his
job and I just like it gave me a pit
like I wish they blurt out his face or
something yeah or just cropped it out
that's like number one
um number two what do you think
I don't know it's like definitely
suspicious honestly I don't know if I
have ever heard of somebody canceling a
concert after the openers already
performed it's literally Next Level and
that's the only reason I'm like slightly
suspicious that something else is going
on because
singers losing their voice is totally
common and it sucks and if he had done
it the morning of or the day before like
we all would have been like where but
it's totally understandable
the the going up until literally
Showtime is so weird to me like to let
people in to buy merch to get drunk like
I don't know it's [__] weird yeah
it's the losing the voicing it's like
even if you're waiting an hour letting
the openers go on like his voice isn't
gonna come back in that time yep yep yep
yep but he could sober up in that time
right but he didn't allegedly he didn't
I also then my other but then like uh he
canceled the shows for the rest of the
week so that makes it seem like he lost
his voice and you know in a week he'll
have his voice back so how does the
canceling of the rest of the shows fit
into the drunk narrative okay well so
the rest of the shows that he canceled
are rescheduled so I know this is like
crazy but maybe he was like really
committing to the bit because nobody
would have believed that his voice was
out if he did a show the next day or
that this weekend whatever it was so
maybe like in order to make it really
believable because he didn't reschedule
the Mississippi show but he did
reschedule the other two that he
canceled yeah maybe like
that's a really expensive way to commit
to the bit though I know I know and
honestly I was hoping he would also
reschedule next week's shows because
that's when he's coming to Florida and I
can't go and then he moved all his shows
to September like that would actually be
fantastic yeah so I um like not to be
selfish I hope his voice stays out it
doesn't come back yeah I also did see
like unverified rumors that he actually
like had gone missing and nobody knew
where he was and they were just hoping
he was going to show up which would make
sense for like the timeline that would
make sense also like I just watched
George and Tammy and this is so George
Jones like generally I was thinking this
is so Kelly canner oh my God in the
opening scene of George and Tammy like
George Jones is so drunk like in the
bathroom he's ripping up money and
flushing it down the toilet and he can't
stand and his management team takes
um
what's the silver tape called duct tape
yeah but like heavier than duct tape and
they taped his legs straight
they taped his knees and threw him out
on stage
it's the next level psychotic so it's
like it's very country of him
he's country but also very important
professional very inconvenient for the
fans they did get refunded but still
like you said they went out to the
stadium they got babysitters they got
drunk and they went home no and then I
was talking with Taylor like you know
most people don't actually buy their
tickets straight from Ticketmaster it
would be great if we all did but like
scalpers get them Bots get them a lot of
people buy their tickets second hand and
after looking into it because I was
curious like only Ticketmaster refunds
so it's like these scalpers not only
don't have to give their money back to
the people who bought it from StubHub
but they actually get a refund from
buying it on Ticketmaster isn't that
crazy even StubHub
yeah it's it's resale resale you don't
get a refund
jeez I didn't know that I know and
that's why like as an artist not that
I'm you know I am a touring artist
myself like you're really not encouraged
to promote any sort of resell websites
well there's a number of reasons for
that I didn't know that of course yeah
this seems like the biggest one
yeah and I remember when StubHub like in
the early days like when I was in high
school we used to like buy tickets on
StubHub like you know one in five times
you were buying fake tickets I do feel
like a lot of like those scam fraud
elements have been vetted on like the
really legit resale websites like
StubHub I don't think that happens as
much anymore I don't think it happens on
websites like step hub no but like Vivid
Seats for sure but we should ask Margo
because she owns the website
StubHub yeah because she's the most
stubborn [__] she'll ever make she's so
stub
um I know this is just like a really
[__] like suspicious ass story and
I'm not letting it go I'm looking into
things yeah I feel like it's not that
crazy of a theory he's definitely in and
out of sobriety uh yeah that's also like
the theme of his album
it's so much about like not drinking but
drinking and he obviously struggles with
this um
and so I just hope that he gets the help
that he needs or that his voice comes
back whatever it is speedily
beedily okay are you ready for our next
story yes we're going to the chapel and
where
gonna get married Lucas Gage and Chris
Appleton got married in Vegas and Kim
officiated and Shania performed so Lucas
Gage from the White Lotus wed the
celebrity hair stylist Chris Appleton
and they both announced that on social
media on April 26th they posted photos
and videos from the ceremony which
included Kim officiating and Shania
performing
this is so weird yeah they went from
like are they dating aren't they dating
and that was like one to two months ago
yeah and now they're hitched
I don't feel like you know this sort of
shotgun Hollywood wedding is you know
built to last but I think they're really
cute together and it's actually really
nice to see like you know Chris who's
like full-time job is to like support
other people like to be the you know
support Kim and JLo to be on the star
and be on stage for like it to be about
him for once yeah and I really enjoyed
that and of course like the the nuptial
details were iconic you know you still
the one that I love the only one I dream
of even though like
it's become a really popular wedding
song and it's kind of weird because it's
like about a man who like treats you
like crap oh yeah you should go with I
Hope You Dance instead
looks like we made it like why why
wouldn't we make it look how far we've
come like it's just like a little weird
I don't know you're not making that's
not as strong of the case
I'll find some more like you can get
through stuff and be proud of that and
say looks like we made it
look how far we've come my baby because
like you know
relationships aren't just like Smooth
Sailing all the time like I actually
think it's a realistic depiction
yeah let me just find the lyrics like
yeah find one nefarious lyric that keeps
you up just like just like that pink
song Claude toast radio listeners will
know right toaster like okay it's just
okay maybe there's actually like nothing
that nefarious in it but it's just like
it's just weird you know we beat the
odds together they said I bet they'll
never make it
it's like trying why was everyone saying
that why was everyone saying that you
know
okay why did why were the odds against
you
okay go off turdy no it's just something
to think about yeah I love thinking
stuff speaking of I Hope You Dance by
Leanne Womack I just I I appreciate
every person who sends me Zach
goitowski's Instagram stories he's now
posting in feed you know fan art of him
and the property brothers and it just
further validates everything I said when
I was you know kind of shook he came at
Irina for coming on the show to be
famous oh and he really thought he
[__] slayed when he said that like
you know like there was blood like and
literally watching his activity on
social media it is so abundantly clear
that there's one person on the show who
came here for fame and his name is
[__] Zach coitowski yeah that's
my case the content is cringe oh it is
painful I am feeling for Bliss
she seems seems happy
I know but like there's a lid for every
pot turtle looks like they made it look
how far they've come my baby
they actually didn't take the long way
that's the next line Mata took the long
way actually they did for the show for
the show they did
for the show yes I guess they I think
they had the wrong song that they were
obsessed with
[Laughter]
um but back to Lucas Gage and Chris
Appleton like I just I there's an
element of bizarity to this entire Saga
so I'm just I'm being I'm skeptical I'm
skeptical I said it Jackie I [__]
said it oh wow I wasn't skeptical I was
just like
okay so so it's the real deal
and I don't know who was there but I
know Chris Appleton has kids and I don't
think that they were there yeah
that's weird but it also felt like very
planned I don't think they were in Vegas
otherwise
I I do think they were I'll tell you why
and I also don't think you can you can
like not plan something when Shania
Twain is performing
um I think they were in Vegas because
Chris Appleton was awarded hairstylist
of the year and I feel like that whole
thing happened in Vegas are you sure I
think that was in LA
let me double check I'm actually not
because it was like uh the the name of
the award ceremony was like the Los
Angeles Fashion Awards and I was like
that's not a real thing
oh yeah daily front row La Awards I I
was just making stuff up again it's so
important that like everybody remembers
and I was just like on the show is made
up I was shocked that Kim went to some
like something called the Los Angeles
Fashion awards that sounds like that was
daily front row that sounds like
something they do like on Real
Housewives Real Housewives of Orange
County Queen yes
I knew what you were gonna say that's so
true knowing that Chris was honored it
was very sweet of her to go it was sweet
of her to go and to obviously plan I'm
sure you know she was the one who booked
Shania yeah also it feels like Kim has
been taking in every Las Vegas residency
recently yes she saw Usher she saw Katy
Perry she saw an Adele yeah I think like
every weekend she goes to Vegas and
takes in a show well I mean if you had a
plane and Vegas was an hour away like
literally you could leave that's how
long it takes you to get to MSG some
nights and that's how long it would take
a normal person to get to the airport
yeah no no I I think it's awesome I
would do the same like that yeah by the
way if I had a plane and lived so close
to La oh and by the way I could get
tickets to whatever I wanted and
probably go backstage maybe even get on
stage like if I had all of those things
you bet your ass would be spending every
weekend in Vegas as well do you think
she'll go to Kelly Clarkson
no because I don't feel like Kim
honestly I don't feel like Kim is good
tasty music honestly but she kind of has
like corny taste in music and I feel
like she would be going for like since
you've been gone
oh actually like I forget that that's
what Kelly's known for like I'm thinking
you know Peace by piece yeah no she's
not going for me slash mine but she
would be going Cuts she would be going
for Breakaway I like that's so like not
what I associate Kelly Clarkson's music
with it's crazy yeah I hope Kim goes
well now actually when you frame it that
way I could totally totally see Kim like
wanting to you know capitalize like on
you know early 2000s Y2K Vibes yeah yeah
totally that's just not the Kelly we
know I'm sorry no that's not Kelly
Brienne
that is that's Kelly Clarkson that is
not Kelly Brienne
my [__] Queen you know do you know
that she has a children's book I did
know that like river runs River yeah and
like there's a song at the end of the
book and it comes with a bear and like
you squeeze the bear and it's Kelly
sings the lullaby goodbye I gotta go
order yeah no I was surprised you didn't
have it I know you know it came out like
before I was in the market for
children's books but um
I didn't know that Kelly sings and
there's a bear goodbye yeah she was on
her talk show talking about it because
apparently it's Ashton Kutcher's uh
son's favorite book before bed oh wow
that's okay it's popular she's got a
cult following with the kids I believe
that
I believe that too are you ready for our
next story I am which would have been a
great story if Ben were hosting but
Aaron Rodgers is coming to the Jets
what you don't know this no Ben is out
of town j-e-t-s Jets Jets Jets he wrote
a lengthy goodbye to the Packers after
his Jets trade went through there were
rumors swirling for like the last few
weeks that he might go to the Jets but
like the Jets always oh my God the Jets
Jackie had not heard Whispers I didn't
even know I have no idea what you're
talking about I thought there were
Whispers that he was gonna retire
yeah no he's going to the Jets
that's exciting because like as a New
York football fan if you're a fan of the
Jets like you know it's just a bleak
life like they've never even had any
sort of like not even not even momentum
and not even hope like it's really like
a sad [__] franchise and the Giants
which is like the other New York team
they're like the cool kids and like
they've won Super Bowls and like even
when they're you know not great they're
still good and so when you're a Jets fan
it's like you're just the dork and the
Giants are like the popular kids so for
this I can't remember like the last time
an actual famous person whose name I
knew played on the Jets like that's
crazy it was Mark Sanchez don't be
[__] rude Tim Tebow
yeah but he was there for like five
minutes and I don't even think he played
Mark Sanchez Mark Sanchez but that was
like Mark Sanchez was famous for being a
jet he wasn't like famous and then came
to the Jets you know and he was famous
because like he was like not supposed to
be that great and he like blew [__] up
he was on the cover of the New York Post
when I was in high school every single
day yeah those were good times well that
could be Iron because not only is like
Aaron Rodgers going to the Jets which is
cool for the Jets um if you're into that
sort of thing but he's coming to New
York slash New Jersey like he's gonna be
your neighbor he's gonna be a star and I
wonder what this means for the Sharks I
wonder what this means for Shailene
yeah yeah I feel like she's so New York
now I feel like she could see a life for
herself in New York maybe it was Green
Bay that was coming between them
she's so not Green Bay she's also so
she's so not in New York City she's not
like a city girl she's very like
Barefoot you know yeah doing Heights in
her bikini
yeah but she could hike on the West Side
Highway The High Line yeah she would
love it
um no this is like so crazy and so
exciting that also means like you know I
like to think you know oh Jackie's
telling a story what does this mean for
me and here's what it means for me it
means like I feel like I might see Aaron
Rodgers at it like a fabulous restaurant
or like a cool Club yeah like zero Bond
yeah I'm sure he'll become a member yeah
I feel like The Nightlife opportunities
and I think Aaron Rodgers likes to throw
down you know he takes the season
seriously but you know he enjoys his
time off yeah I just feel like he's not
gonna like New York
I know I don't where is he from
originally like like born and raised
yeah hold on I'm looking it up
oh Chico California oh man that's where
Ryan from the OC was from Chico oh wow
and he went to Berkeley
so yeah maybe maybe he hasn't spent a
lot of time in New York maybe he doesn't
know how much he's gonna love it
yeah I don't know
I don't know but I'm excited I'm excited
for New York
I need to ask Zach Shapiro what this
means like Zach Shapiro's Ben's not
really into football like he follows
everything but he's really into
basketball
um Shapiro is like our family football
fanatic and he he cares about the New
York teams like my husband doesn't yeah
he's a huge Giants fan so I have to ask
him what's what this means for me and
for the for the state and for the
community well it could mean good things
for you like it could mean like now
maybe I'll go to a Jets game and it'll
be something to go do
yeah by the way I feel like when we got
into our 49ers era I really appreciated
like how fun really truly fun it can be
to go to a football game like it is fun
to be a part of it also there were
rumors that Aaron Rodgers was going to
go to the 49ers I think
[__] okay but let's go let's go back to
the 49ers like our team doesn't have a
they don't have the quarterback that
they can lean quarterback
who like who are we thinking I know that
people were actually thinking Tom Brady
might go but he officially retired again
so yeah no they need like we need some
fresh blood
yeah we need like a hot young thing we
need like a matte saracen
no we don't Minnie to Matt Harrison out
of Texas
no we need the one who got hurt to get
better because he was like brought all
that yeah he was all that Brock
if you go to his Instagram he's such a p
drum it's like Jesus this Jesus that I'm
like yes Brock yes that's beautiful
yeah well that concludes your sports
news for the day feel like you needed to
know where Aaron is going
and what this means for Shailene and
what it means for turdy's backyard
right before you dive into the next
story let me tell you that today's
episode is brought to you by Topgolf
it's golf it's not golf it's Topgolf so
they've got a bunch of things at their
Topgolf locations that make them you
know the golf they got the clubs the
balls the t's the turf the ball picker
upper thing
um but they also have a lot of stuff
that makes it knock off like great music
loud music giant Targets in the Fairway
huge TVs handcrafted food and beverage
menus it is fabulous I have can tell you
firsthand we have spent you know many a
night at Topgolf and it is fun we're
going back next week actually in
Asheville it is so fun we're obviously
not like big into golf when I tell you
how much fun we had we got so into it
and we were all girls we were like I
guess we'll just like go and like dance
and stuff we got so into it it was so
competitive Jackie O ended up winning
but we enjoyed everything that Topgolf
had to offer that's the food and
beverage
that they do actually have price
gameplay on Tuesdays
um we enjoyed the music we enjoyed the
Vibes the bays are heated in the winter
and they're cold in the summer I'm very
temperature conscious and it's nice to
know that they are too over at Topgolf
so
make sure to check out a Topgolf if
you're in a town that has one it's such
a great way to spend a girls night a
date night couples night out that's what
we're doing next week so much fun
because it's golf it's not golf it's
Topgolf download the app and book ahead
and to come and play around on half
price Tuesday or any other day today's
episode is also brought to you by the
perfect bar
the original refrigerated protein bar
you know and love for those of you that
live under a rock or who rudely skip
through our ads here are the fast five
things that you need to know about the
perfect bar one it's made with freshly
ground nut butter organic honey and 20
organic superfoods two they have up to
17 grams of protein and they come in 10
delicious flavors plus little snack size
bars that are perfect for busy toasters
on the go three they're made with only
whole food ingredients and they contain
no artificial preservatives that they
are actually stored in the fridge
because that's how freaking fresh they
are four they have the most seconding
cookie dough texture perfect bar is
truly unlike any other protein bar out
there and five if you aren't already
convinced their non-GMO project verified
they're gluten-free they're soy free
they're kosher and they're low GI they
are perfect to just throw in your purse
before a long day a travel day I
literally have one in my purse for my
flight tomorrow it is perfect it'll keep
you full it'll keep you feeling good
perfect bar knows it'll be Love At First
Bite so for a limited time they're
offering you a chance to try the
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for their
email or texts and upload a picture of
your receipt from your local grocery
store and they'll reimburse you for the
cost of one bar it'll go directly into
your venmower PayPal account which is
pretty cool all you have to do is go to
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today happy snacking thanks Claudia
what can I say except you're welcome no
I don't want to ruin your appetite with
the next story but oh what the new
season season six of Black Mirror has
been confirmed yet with a June release
and they just released the teaser which
I'm literally too scared to even watch
no I'm not [__] watching that [__]
the show is disgusting and it's
depressed depravity at its finest but
it's also really smart and really good
and
it gives you a whole new perspective on
life and you have to watch it and it's
also star studded this season yes so
this season's roster includes Aaron Paul
Annie Murphy oh I love her that's uh
shit's creek it's Alexis yes Kate Mara
Michael Sarah
Salma Hayek Rory Culkin and many others
who's Rory Culkin the one from
succession no that's Kieran Culkin oh
[__] and then there's Macaulay and then
there's a third there was always a third
Googling I had no idea yeah and he's
definitely from somebody
wait yeah wait hold on the way that this
family like has this the genetics of
like serial killers and they all ended
up as like famous actors they all look
like serial killers but what have we
seen him in I'm not recognizing anything
from his
who did he play in Waco played like that
guy you know oh no I remember him he's
from Halston the Netflix miniseries he
played Joel Schumacher oh I don't oh I
did watch that no he played David
Thibodeaux he was like one of the new
recruits he was kind of like our eyes
and ears
yeah yeah yeah that show was so [__]
good we really quickly when you were
going through the people who were in it
uh K Mara I really wish she never did
that show on FX about the teacher who
has sex with her student because
honestly the same laughs
the teacher who had sex with their
student she was so convincing in that to
me she's a [__] pedophile like I
can't move past it no it was such a
deeply like authentic performance like I
see her as a teacher wow do you want to
disturb you want to pull a Meghan
Trainor
no I don't wanna I'm not gonna say what
you want me to say you don't want to go
to jail tonight
no that's not how I plan to spend my
evening
um so the season looks you know just as
dysfunctional dark and dystopian as ever
but uh a new addition is that it seems
like they might not be one-off episodes
so they've always been like Standalone
installments but the showrunner hinted
that season six follows a new model a
log night a log line notes that the
sixth season of Black Mirror is the most
unpredictable unclassifiable and
unexpected yet so it might
have more of a story arc like continuity
between each episode it used to be like
you could just watch Random episodes
kind of like Law and Order like you
would just watch Random episodes they
had totally different characters totally
different places they were set in like
and I I've seen a bunch of episodes but
I never watched them front to back
people would just be like oh you have to
watch that one or you have to watch that
one it's not confirmed but like the the
showrunner said like I always felt Black
Mirror should feature stories that are
entirely distinct from one another and
keep people people and myself surprised
it should be a series that can be easily
defined and can keep reinvented
Reinventing itself but then he also
feels the need to challenge everything
like everything about Black Mirror is
like challenging
usual assumption so anything [__]
goes with this show girder loins
also does it feel like it's been a
really long time since the last it's
been three years I think yeah okay yeah
yeah season five came out in 2019 right
so four years this is long-awaited
that's crazy
the show like the people who think of
this [__] are so [__] up in the head
like I can okay obviously obviously you
want to go to a dark place but think of
some of the more compelling episodes I'm
on a roll riding So High
by the way I never even saw that episode
I just love that song oh it's cute it's
also the premise of the book that we
read for the redheads Clara and the sun
oh
just like oh a doll that's like your
friend and companion
oh so you mean the life-size starring
starring Tyra Banks and Lindsay Lohan
yeah yeah they all are pretty similar
um but life size did it first then there
were other episodes too like that guy
who's like bring people home from work
and like put them in his computer sad
[__] episode with Landry from Friday
Night Lights who's this [__] freak
who like digitally kidnaps his
co-workers who he doesn't like and they
make them live in this alternate reality
for the rest of their lives right
oh my God that [__] show and then he
ends up spoiler alert dying and like
they they did it but like I can't and
then also the one with like Bryce Dallas
Howard where she's a bridesmaid I hate
that one her social credit score is like
not good enough so she keeps trying to
get it up but she winds up with like
and then like really bad I think she
winds up like dead or like arrested she
was like on the side of the road like
hitchhiking I think she ends up dead
yeah
the show is churned like it's really not
okay in any way I know but I look
forward to the personal internal battle
I'm gonna have about whether or not to
watch it oh yeah I'm totally watching it
I don't know
you know I need to know like what level
of like gory like they really just [__]
with your head sometimes and you know
what that's not good all the time like
no life is hard enough but I do feel
like so many things wind up happening in
the world and then we're like oh my God
that's like a Black Mirror episode and
it takes Black Mirror to like show us
some of the dangers of like social media
social yeah technology like that no
you're so right we were just talking
about this episode where
um the punishment for a crime that this
person committed was that they like wake
up every single day they forget every
single they forget everything that
happened before and they like have to go
through the same day over and over again
well and it people attend and watch it
like it's a museum
um
yeah
messed up stuff no deeply unwell people
coming up with these Concepts I wish
them well
yeah okay are you ready for our fifth
and final story
the final story
[Music]
back together again
and that's a magic number
[Music]
it's a little light exciting Bachelor
Fair because Becca kufrin is pregnant
and expecting her first child with her
fiance Thomas Jacobs who she met on
Bachelor in Paradise whom she proposed
to correct oh yeah oh yeah
just it's important that we not forget
that I forgot and I no I couldn't that's
the only thing I think of when I think
of Becca Cooper and her man I honestly
did not know that they were still
together right there and that actually
is really cute and I feel like you know
in Bachelor World a lot of people get
together a lot of people get engaged
even and especially on Paradise yeah to
either get married or have a baby with
someone like makes it you know a lot
more serious official and so these two
are going the distance she announced on
Wednesday that her and Thomas Jacobs her
fiance will be expanding their family
this fall Party of Five coming September
2023. five
I think there's probably dogs in the
picture
oh oh my God I hate when people do that
like it's so confusing I know but like
what do you think you're gonna leave
Theo out of your announcement one day no
Theo is the announcement like he's here
get with the program there is a jog in
the picture and the sonogram looks like
one little one so five so that's one two
that's four three four hold on maybe
there's two it's the fifth maybe she's
having twins
it looks like one
baby
I think there might be two dogs two dogs
oh okay
I was literally like typing out
investigative like what is going I was
like maybe he has a child from another
relationship yeah
yeah no that good thing that you called
that out party five
I'm like damn that's a big family yeah
well they're growing their fam anything
that's really sweet
that's nice I mean
Becca kufrin like wouldn't be where she
is right now if Ari leindeg didn't like
dump her on television and I know
everybody made Ari and Lauren like the
villains out of that story but I think
now you know knowing what we know Ari
and Lauren have multiple children she's
engaged has a baby on the way seems like
everything worked out the way that it
was supposed to work out don't you think
Jax I do think turd
turd thinks yes
[Laughter]
thank turd
I turd yes think
absolutely those are the Fast Five and I
didn't choose them and it was an
absolute pleasure
um this is Thursday's episode Friday's
episode is going to be me and Shannon
we're going to be podcasting live from
Palm Springs before we head out for our
first official day of Stagecoach which
is so exciting how are you feeling about
Stagecoach do you see the weather
stop yeah I was prepared I knew it was
going to be over 100 degrees I'm okay
with the weather I am packed I do
believe I have like all my outfits
um I was feeling good until Shannon sent
me a picture of her outfits
um
you want me to send you them I do let me
send it to you right now it's vomit
worthy I saw in your story that you um
you were vomiting
like let me just send you one and you'll
know like why I don't want to go anymore
but your outfits are really strong
Claude like it's not about an outfits
it's like about the whole look you know
what I mean like just look at the [__]
picture of Shannon and you'll understand
why I'm no longer interested in
attending this festival with that you
know devious wench yeah no that's really
cool stuff but also you could think of
it this way like there's things in there
that you could borrow
I know and Shannon's so generous she was
like what can I bring she's bringing me
a jacket she's like you need she's
getting me sunglasses like she's being
so generous maybe she has the belt that
you need
I just don't think like wear the same
belt size you know
fine did you try on the Belt that you
bought with your outfit I I didn't try
it on like I'm just I'm just crossing my
finger you're a raw dog in it yeah I
bought a bell it's like an expensive
belt and I'll just return it if I don't
wear it yeah
that's fine yeah so like that's a little
bit of update for me so I'm just got a
spray tan I'm literally gonna go to bed
I have to wake up at the crack of dawn
and make sure you're following me on
Instagram this weekend because I'm gonna
be at Stagecoach like living it up and
make sure you're following Jackie too
because she's always doing interesting
things over there that is so sweet TL I
can't wait to keep up with your story by
the way do not call me TL I know I won't
I just did because I know that I reached
like my turd maximum I know people get
like annoyed but you know what I don't
get no it's like I don't I'm still gonna
call you turd turdy like whatever but I
do know that there's like a limit so if
I could switch it Up remix it
yeah then I'll try and do that but I
don't think TL is the one
I don't think so either
um I'm excited to follow along on your
weekend of fun in the sun with the girly
swirly twirlies we will miss you I will
miss you too and just be like living
vicariously through you in the music but
like you know what the lineup's not my
dream lineup so I'll be okay it's still
it's definitely a missable lineup yeah
but like you're going for
the fun and the camaraderie exactly
exactly because I like
um I like it
I like you Jackie and I love podcasting
with you and thanks everyone for
listening to the toaster Monday Morning
Show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast any podcast can be found so
that Spotify iTunes touch your public
radio I read a castbox all the places
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing day and we'll see you I'll see
you on Friday and then we'll see you
next week love ya love ya bye